well with the chancellor just sitting
down after his comments to the cbi let's
get some reaction now from uh the
government uh straight away shall we we
can speak now to the attorney general
sweller braverman who's live in the
palace of westminster thank you very
much for being with us this evening
and we just heard from the chancellor
rishi sunak he said we have a collective
responsibility to help the most
vulnerable we stand ready to do more
what are you going to do
well
the government has already acted whilst
we accept times are tough for many
households around the country because of
inflation caused largely because of
factors outside our control i must add
you know we're seeing similar trends in
the us
and the eu it's right the government
should act and that's why we've already
announced a 22 billion pound package of
support to help people particularly
those on the lowest incomes with the
cost of living and much of that is
phased out across the year so whether
it's raising the national living wage
whether it's helping families with their
energy bills through the 150 pound
council tax rebate that will set is set
to increase later this year or whether
it's the biggest ever cut in fuel duty
uh and there are many other measures
that we've already announced which are
already taking effect which are designed
specifically to help all of those people
struggling right now with the cost of
living and you're talking there about
what's already been announced um but
rishi sunette was pretty clear there
that he's signaling that more is to come
he said our response will evolve we
stand ready to do more and i guess my
question is you know lots of families
are going to be really really worried
about how they're going to make ends
meet we've seen these inflation figures
nine percent the biggest rise in 40
years he was pretty clear to the
businesses what's going to happen he
said in the autumn budget we will cut
your taxes why can't you be clear to
families and working people and people
who are really struggling up and down
the country why can't you be clear to
ordinary people as well what are you
actually going to do
well i think we have been very clear and
we've actually taken action in november
almost two million of the lowest income
working households who receive universal
credit will have been benefiting from a
cash boost worth a thousand pounds on
average and that's thanks to our
reduction to the universal credit taper
rate and an increase to claimants work
allowances we've been clear uh about the
150 pound council tax rebate to support
people with their energy bills we've
been clear we're doubling the household
support fund with an extra 500 million
pounds available to help directly those
people most in need so i think we've
actually been quite clear there is a lot
of support there and of course the
chancellor is right we're always going
to be keeping a watching brief on the
situation and we'll respond as things
evolve well just to jump in because
you're saying the chancellor wants to
keep a watching eye on the situation and
that's really what i'm asking about i
know i understand the stuff that's been
announced already but i think what is
clear is the chancellor and i think many
of your own mps are conceding that you
are going to take further action our
response will evolve we stand ready to
do more and my question is what what is
that more what what are you going to do
well that is a decision for the
chancellor in terms of how he announces
that uh but i'm very pleased with what
we've heard uh this evening and i'm just
hearing it secondhand on reports in the
media that he wants to cut taxes as
conservatives we instinctively want to
keep taxation low we trust individuals
and people to spend their money better
than government ultimately that's the
big difference between us and the labour
party and we want to ensure that
taxation is low and that's why from july
of this year we are increasing the
national insurance thresholds to save a
typical worker 330 pounds a year with 70
percent of employees to be brought off
as a result of those changes that we're
making so those are the things that
there's a tax cuts that are going to be
coming into effect i understand you know
the conservative principle that you know
a marginal pound is is better spent by
an individual than the state i get that
but we are in extraordinary times here
inflation is at nine percent there's a
lot of people on benefits who are
worried about keeping their children
warm about putting food on the table so
actually for them
perhaps that marginal pound spent by the
state is is the difference between
keeping their families warm and not or
or getting an extra loaf of bread at the
weekend right
do they move
as i said at the outset we're very much
aware that many families will be
struggling right now and particularly
for those people on benefits there are a
huge amount of resources available to
them for example if you look at an
average household in the outgoings it's
things like their bills their utility
bills that's why i won't mention it a
third time but help on council tax but
for people on benefits it goes even
further there's help to assist on water
bills there's help to assist um on
paying child care that's not just
available for people on benefits that's
actually available to a very wide number
of people and actually there's many
people thousands of households who are
not actually claiming the 15 or 13 at
the same time though hours free child
care paid for by the government there's
going up by 3.7
universal credit's going up by 3.7
inflation is going up today by 9 i mean
i'm not a mathematician but you know and
i know that things are getting very very
hard for families and actually just
saying actually look there's loads of
help around there people just need to
look a bit harder to find it is that
really
sufficient
listen i i as i say we are very
cognizant of the struggles that many
families are facing however i just want
to say it's not fair to say that the
government has done nothing and that
we're somehow not responding okay we've
announced a 22 billion pound package
that's significant we've announced
significant tax cuts um
when do you think more help as rishi
sunak signaled when will that come will
that come in july before the summer
recess
listen you're asking me something that
really is going to be a decision for the
chancellor and the prime minister and
then the cabinet uh he's made an
announcement today that's going to be
worked through and in terms of uh how
that's announced um but i can't give you
any timelines on announcements but if
the chancellor says there will be tax
cuts coming i trust i trust him and i'm
very glad to hear it okay now you of
course are the attorney general you're
the legal advisor to the government
if the uk government unilaterally scraps
or
ignores parts of the northern ireland
protocol without the agreement of the eu
with of course whom you signed the
brexit deal with would that be breaking
the law
i can't get into the details of legal
advice unfortunately i know that might
sound a bit odd but there's a convention
in government which means that the law
officers can't comment on the fact or
the content of their legal advice but
we do know uh what the foreign secretary
has said and she has made very clear in
her statement yesterday that the action
proposed by the government has a lawful
basis and there will be a statement
which will be issued by the government
in due course setting out a bit more
detail behind that so i'm not able to go
into the details behind the legalities
what i am able to say is that the
measures announced are important vital
and have my support it's really uh
there's there are challenges and
problems in northern ireland caused by
the operation of the protocol uh in
relation to uh i mean and the effects of
those problems are visible for everyone
to see we've seen the collapse of
stormont so that people in northern
ireland are not going to be getting the
services that they deserve because of a
paralysis in their government we've seen
um more uh
burdens and costs uh imposed on traders
based in northern ireland because of
excessive
bureaucracy uh um you know affected by
the eu's application of the rules in the
protocol so there are problems uh we
want to get stormont back up and running
we want to ensure that
northern ireland's place in within the
uh territory of the united kingdom is
secured and reassured and that's why
these proposals are very important
i just want to ask a really sort of
simple uh question and you know you're
saying that there's a convention not to
publish the uh legal advice but at the
same time we are in uh quite an
extraordinary situation uh the situation
of course in northern ireland uh
extremely uh um you know fragile very
lots of people are very very concerned
about what's happening there will you
commit to publishing
the legal advice on this
the foreign secretaries make clear that
we're going to be publishing a statement
so that's a bit different though isn't
it so just can we just unpick that bit
will you publish the legal advice that
you gave to the government or are we
just going to rely on on a statement
what will be in that statement
what's actually happening no we're not
going to publish the legal advice it's
incredibly rare uh for the government to
publish its legal advice i don't think
it's actually uh ever really been done
before so if that there are you know any
lawyer will know uh legal advice is
privileged and confidential that means
even more in the context of government
and uh you know this is an important
issue and uh you know the government has
the right to keep its uh legal advice
private and confidential i i hope you'd
respect that anybody else has that right
but i think that what the government is
doing as i said it will be setting out a
bit more detail about the legal basis so
that people have a bit more of an
understanding about why we think the
action taken is lawful i just want to
try to work out your red lines on what's
happening at the minute with the
protocol because you know talking to
some people on the eu side they say look
we're willing to try and find a landing
zone where there's fewer checks needed
do you want to see the role of the
european court of justice removed in
ruling and disputes in northern ireland
yes
uh the european court of justice should
not be the final arbiter of disputes
between the uk and the eu and the bill
that we have committed to introducing
will reflect that
there's no way there's no way that
you're going to get an agreement with
the eu on this is there frankly if if
that is a red line for you
well i i've i've been talking about
issues relating to the european union
for many for too many years now to know
that uh those in the media who predict
uh the worse aren't often uh proven to
be right sophie with respect so i i
wouldn't want to prejudge the outcome of
what happens with these uh with this
issue i very much hope the eu will uh
respond uh creatively uh positively
constructively the ideal outcome for all
of us is that we get a renegotiated
settlement that works for
the united kingdom and in particular
works for the uh the northern ire the
communities in northern ireland and
upholds the primacy of the good friday
agreement the foundation of peace but
also respects the uh the the boundaries
of the european union single market
which the uk really does pay a lot of
respect to okay and very just just
quickly because i do want to talk to you
about one other topic as well but you
know some people listening to you will
find this frankly quite astonishing
that the uk is willing to unilaterally
effectively rip up major parts of an
agreement that you signed that people
said would lead to
checks along the rsc that boris johnson
sold as a brilliant deal and now you're
just saying that actually no we can just
unilaterally rip the whole thing up
and it's not such a great deal after all
what is going on
i think what most people will find very
astonishing uh
more worryingly actually is how the
situation in northern ireland has been
detrimentally affected by the eu's
application of the protocol we and 54 of
the 19 members of the northern ireland
assembly are in favor of keeping the um
protocol as it is rather than scrapping
it
well well you'll know well actually uh
the majority all parties actually agree
that there are profound problems with
the protocol so that's actually not
controversial and the majority the
largest group on the executive the
unionists all agree that the protocol
must be changed fundamentally so i i
don't think you know i think the people
in northern ireland 54 of the 90 members
of the northern ireland assembly are
from parties who are in favor of not
doing what you want to do with the
protocol but in effectively maintaining
it
well what we know is that in northern
ireland uh because of the eu's
application of the protocol we are
seeing onerous
checks and costs being applied to
traders the the chairman of marx and
spencer's has come out and said that the
way it's being implemented is
is bureaucratic it's making it's very
difficult for uh making all it's almost
making it's making it almost impossible
for business to be done
and that actually the disproportionate
level of checks uh just doesn't really
isn't justifiable and that's what we
want to remedy we want to find a
compromise and we want to definitely
find uh an agreement that works as i say
for northern ireland for all communities
for both communities and for the eu and
for the uk uh now we have seen more
allegations and some allegations about a
conservative
mp arrested on suspicion of rape now he
hasn't been named
now previously it was quite common for
you know suspects to be named after an
arrest that that seems to have changed
more recently on privacy concerns unless
there's a strong public interest to name
them
do you think it's right that the mp
should not be named at this point
well first of all i think it is
obviously
shocking and worrying that we've had
this report i have to i don't know that
many details i only know as much as i'm
hearing on the media and i don't know
who it is importantly but what we do
know is that someone has been arrested
and i think the reason uh this person
has been asked to stay away from
parliamentary estate i think that's a an
important step forward however
i think that if the moment if the whip
is removed at this stage it then becomes
obvious who this person is
and
that will also potentially prejudice the
anonymity of the victim who may at this
stage still want to remain
anonymous so i think that we're at a
very delicate stage and i think
steps need to be taken very carefully
and of course you know
at the right time and in the right
circumstances uh a person may be named
but i think right now it's premature
okay now just to ask very briefly to end
about the wider culture at westminster
and to be clean i'm not talking i'm
talking in general i'm not talking about
specific case
is there a misogyny problem at
westminster and if there is what needs
to change
honestly and speaking uh based on my own
experience no
um i have been in parliament now as an
mp for seven years i've been in politics
for almost 20 years it is uh male
dominated that's true but is there a
culture of misogyny no way i see many uh
the vast majority of my male
counterparts of all parties are
courteous respectful and supportive and
unfortunately as we see in all
workplaces there is a very small
minority for whom uh you know their
their behavior for sure but is there a
culture no okay uh thank you very much
for being on the programme today uh so
ella braverman there thank you very much